1999's the mummy blew audiences away
with its blend of high octane action and
chilling horror but what has the cast
been up to in the two decades since the
film's release
we're here to catch you up on the
goings-on of the mummies cast from the
oscars they've won to the challenges
they've faced
brendan fraser plays the lead role of
rick o'connell a rugged adventurer who
leads an expedition to hamunoptra
the city of the dead where the high
priest imotep's corpse resides
when it turns out that the terrifying
legends about this mysterious city are
true
his travels take a deadly turn initially
frazier found continued success in the
sequels the mummy returns and the mummy
tomb of the dragon emperor
he also starred in a remake of the 1967
film bedazzled
looney tunes back in action and the
oscar-winning film
crash however after being assaulted in
2003
losing his mother and going through a
bitter divorce
the star took it upon himself to leave
hollywood behind frazier told gq
magazine
i bought into the pressure that comes
with a professional life that's being
molded and shaped and guided and managed
that requires what they call a thick
skin i just felt i couldn't be a part of
it
i didn't feel that i belonged in recent
years though frazier has made a modest
return to the industry
you may have spotted him in series such
as trust condor
or doom patrol where he provides his own
idiosyncratic take on the dc comics hero
robot man after reading a loud from the
ancient
book of the dead librarian and aspiring
egyptologist evelyn carnahan
unintentionally wakes up imitep from his
eternal slumber
played by rachel weiss carnahan must
fight to survive as the undead high
priest strives to sacrifice her
in order to resurrect his long dead
lover following the success of the mummy
and
the mummy returns vice went on to build
an impressive film career for herself
in addition to winning an oscar for her
role in the constant gardener
she also starred in numerous other
highly regarded films such as the
lobster
the favorite and the light between
oceans her personal life has been just
as busy
after spending a number of years being
married to renowned director darren
aronofsky she got hitched to daniel
craig and became
a mother of two john hannah plays
evelyn's brother
jonathan carnahan who sets the story in
motion by giving her a map to hamanopdra
after confessing that he stole it from
rick who has since been imprisoned the
two set off to free him and enlist him
to travel with them to the ancient city
of the dead
after starring in the mummy trilogy
hannah focused more on television
where he became a regular on numerous
series including carnival
trust me and agents of shield however he
made appearances in a few films as well
the hurricane and ghost sun being two
that he has claimed to be particularly
fond of his newest endeavors include the
sci-fi comedy
the intergalactic adventures of max
cloud and
the auschwitz report patricia velazquez
plays anuk sunyamu
imatep's illicit lover and pharaoh
seti's mistress
after having an affair behind the
pharaoh's back and subsequently killing
him in order to keep their secret
they both face fatal consequences that
echo through time
velasquez has continued her acting
career since the mummy starring in tv
series like arrested development
american family and the l word she also
played the role of patricia alvarez in
the horror film the curse of lagurona
outside of hollywood velasquez is also a
committed activist
in 2002 she founded the waiutaia
foundation
which works to support indigenous
communities in latin america
she also published an autobiography
straight walk in 2015
in which she officially came out as a
lesbian in the book she writes
as my daughter started growing up and i
was teaching her to be honest and proud
i knew it was time for me to set an
example which meant facing my truth
arnold vaslu plays the memorable and
terrifying imitep
who not only wipes out a group of
treasure hunters but also brings back
the 10 plagues of ancient egypt
though we start in the sequel the mummy
returns he did not reprise his role in
the final installment of the trilogy
tomb of the dragon emperor however he
did go on to act in many other films and
tv series
including 24 gi joe the rise of cobra
gi joe retaliation blood diamond and tom
clancy's jack ryan
he is also a prolific voice actor having
appeared in
everything from all-star superman to
voltron legendary defender
jonathan hyde plays dr alan chamberlain
who hopes to strike it rich on his
expedition to egypt
traveling with a group of treasure
hunters to cairo he opens a chest that
contains the book of the dead
because of this he is marked with the
curse of imitep who consumes his life
energy
killing him since the mummy he has
appeared in films such as land of the
blind and crimson peak
and tv series such as the strain and
troll hunter's tales of arcadia
he also has many theater accolades
including roles in king lear
peter pan and julius caesar his most
recent work was his performance as
richard nixon in frost
nixon at the sheffield crucible theater
kevin j o'connor plays benny gabor a
selfish treasure hunter who's willing to
use
anyone in order to come out on top this
mindset leads him to swear his devotion
to imitep
and ultimately ends up ensuring his
untimely demise
besides playing benny o'connor is likely
best known for his roles as igor and van
helsing and henry in
there will be blood he's also been
involved in the stephen king miniseries
11 2263
the television adaptation of joseph
heller's catch-22
and on becoming a god in central florida
oded fair plays the fierce warrior
artist bay who leads the medjay in
hamanoptra
the medjay are descendants of pharaoh
seti's palace guards who guard immitep's
tomb
though ardith warns the explorers to
leave they choose not to heed his
warnings
consequently they must turn to him for
help after imitep is resurrected
in addition to the mummy fair has
starred in deuce bigelow male gigolo
and three resident evil movies
specifically
apocalypse extinction and retribution he
has also landed regular roles in several
series including the first
when heroes fly and once upon a time he
married producer rhonda tollefson in
2000
and his three children with her eric
avari plays dr terence bay
evelyn's boss and curator of the cairo
museum of antiquities
later in the film we find out that he's
actually working with the magi to
prevent imitep from being
resurrected you may otherwise know him
best as cecil anderson
in the 2002 comedy mr deeds or is to
fall in the 2001 remake of the planet of
the apes
he's also taken on roles in numerous tv
series such as heroes
the middleman leverage hung the brink
and the chosen in 2015 he made his
directorial debut with the film
chasing eagle rock he's even worked as a
voice actor most prominently portraying
master rahul
in the destiny series of video games
stephen dunham plays dr henderson a
gentleman who tags along with the
treasure hunters in hopes of becoming
rich
as we've already recalled things don't
end well for them after they open the
chest
that contains the book of the dead his
most prominent work besides the mummy
was his supporting role in the 2008
comedy get smart
and for playing dr chamberlain in
monster in law he also acted in tv
series such as
dag and oh grow up his role in
paranormal activity
4 ended up being his last acting gig as
he sadly passed away from a heart attack
at the age of 48.
corey johnson plays mr daniels another
member of the ill-fated treasure-hunting
troop
despite his swift end in the mummy he's
consistently proved his staying power as
an actor
with roles in blockbusters such as the
bourne ultimatum
captain phillips and ex machina like
numerous others in the mummy cast he has
dabbled in theater
his most notable accolade is his
performance as mitch in a streetcar
named desire
johnson's newest endeavors include roles
in the short films swept under the rug
and the full-length feature morbius
lastly tuck watkins plays mr burns
another member of the treasure hunter
troupe who fails to escape the curse of
imitep
once the ancient chest is opened he's
best known for his role as
david vickers on the soap opera one life
to live and also his role as bob hunter
on desperate housewives
if that's not your cup of tea you can
find him on the mystery web series where
the bears are
or on the second season of the dark
comedy series black monday
in 2013 he came out as gay on an episode
of marie
and announced that he'd become the
father of twins via a surrogate
he recalled his thoughts when he was
much younger i knew i was gay
and i knew one day i was going to be a
dad though the mummy was released to
mixed reviews in 1999
it has surely become a movie that all of
us remember fondly
it was the epitome of a summer
blockbuster incredible action sequences
spooky curses and the triumph of good
over evil
but beyond just being a fun movie the
mummy helped pave the way for many
subsequent action films while
simultaneously
taking cues from the much older films
that influenced it
it's a classic and we have no doubt that
it will continue to be
for many years to come check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one